why don't we go first via discord uh by
the way the discord
davidpakman.com discord
let's speak to juni from chicago juni
you were on the air what is on your mind
today
uh hello david do you hear me okay yes i
do
great uh my question for you is um
if you do you feel any
concern for the body administration or
for the democratic chances in uh 2022.
yeah so so big picture when a party
takes the white house in one election
they tend to lose seats in the house the
following midterm so that would be a bad
signal for
for democrats in 2022 that being said i
think these circumstances are are
different and i think that
it has been even if you don't like if
you don't align exactly with joe biden's
policy
it has been so refreshing in a sense to
return to something
approximating normality that and
there are so many radical right-wing
nuts that would be up for re-election in
2022
that i think it's quite plausible that
democrats could do fine
i just think it's too early to tell i do
think joe biden needs
at least one more major legislative
accomplishment
uh infrastructure would be good or or
something else i think he needs at least
one more major thing for democrats to be
better positioned in 22.
uh yeah i i agree with um all of that
um the reason why i was uh asking that
was because
i just saw his recent uh i think was
morning console poll
and it showed him uh under uh
uh 50 uh for the first time
and yeah i guess i'm just not um i'm not
seeing enough urgency from the
administration at least
right now uh you know like getting the
filibuster gone
uh trying to get uh hr one pass or
anything like that and i understand that
like
joe manchin is an obstacle but i i
really
like i guess i i i wanted more from joe
biden absolutely listen we always we
always like he's doing
quite enough and that's why i have a bit
of a anxiety for 2022
but right it's still fairly early yeah
you know we still got like another six
months
before like campaigning right you know
2022 is uh underway
yep and i think yeah i guess you know
i'm just very
concerned overall about like their
chances
after like i agree like his recent poll
i guess i totally agree with you juni
all right let's demand more and we will
follow it that's
juni from chicago one of our sponsors
is privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
com privacy.com pacman